hey everybody Chris Waters here Rob
Handler hi what's up Rob what's up man
you want to play some
Halo sure
yes uh we're here to play some Halo
Master Chief Collection uh we're big
halo fans would you say that's accurate
absolutely yeah absolutely Big Time Halo
memories from back in the day uh and
we're going to get to play through one
level from each of the Halo games
included in the Master Chief Collection
so that's Combat Evolved Halo 2
aniversary Halo 3 and Halo 4 going to
start at the beginning I feel like
Combat Evolved Anniversary uh this is
game I actually reviewed for gam spot
and gave it a good score it's it's a
great game uh we're going to take a look
at like switching back and forth between
like what it used to look like what it
looks like now we're going to get to see
some of the cutcenes that have been uh
reimagined by blur I don't know if if
you guys watched that trailer that came
out this morning oh I did like how many
times would you say I watched it so many
times so many specifically teal term uh
the specifically the warthog reveal I
yelled I literally was I'm home I was
like
oh I've been on that I've been watching
that on repeat delightful oh yeah all
right let's play some Halo here so uh
this is the main menu let's we can take
a look at this uh we're not going to go
too much into the other stuff now
multiplayer is not up going to be
showable till later on but we'll jump
right into the campaigns and like
they've said uh everything's unlocked
right from the start so we're going to
go ahead into uh
C and um gonna choose from the missions
one we're going to play is the silent
cartographer but here you see they're
just all lined up all ready for you and
uh then there's a few you can see sort
of at the top there uh there's a few
stages you go through for selection so
for first you Choose Your Mission uh
then you've got your scoring and time uh
so you can you know play with scoring
and your your time thing on that's
something they introduced uh with
anniversary or Halo 4 I think they had
that in there as well so a time frame
you know Beat the Clock essentially yeah
beat the clock and also you know work uh
those medals and those sort of uh you
know stunt kills to get like points
basically and also scoring is uh the
skulls are also the multiplier sort of
applies right visuals in music you can
set the default as remastered or classic
but you can also switch between them
with the Press of a button so that's
what we're going to do uh then usually I
play through on heroic personally uh I
was playing Halo 2 on heroic ahead of
this stream and getting my ass kicked so
yeah Halo 2 was really tough maybe we'll
start uh with heroic on Halo CE and then
see where we go from there uh then of
course a bunch of skulls uh which we oh
all right cool it you know stuff like
your Shields only recharge when you
melee enemies auto aim disabled weapons
dropped by AI have half the ammo death
death resets you like you die you
restart the level Covenant weapons how
do they work the motion tracker is
disabled enemies have increased Health
every shot's worth Twi the ammo so like
if you were to stack all these things
you know like your
multiplier is pretty intense but but
it's also going to be really hard we're
not we're not going to do that uh then
of course they have the non-scoring ones
grunt birthday party and every time
respawn a random element of your HUD is
disabled I don't I don't know what the
point of that is so then like
continually I guess it goes back and
forth yeah just random so all right
we're GNA start this uh we're going to
start uh with the cut scene we'll keep
it quiet for you guys if you want to
this a great here throughout it but uh
the silent card tographer a Halo Combat
evolve classic I was playing a little
earlier so that's why it's giving me
this uh I like made made it to one
checkpoint before but we're starting
fresh fresh and so clean
clean oh I can't
wait so you know someone asked can you
play Old Graphics all the time
absolutely with by pushing the start or
back boxes the boxes on the Xbox One
controller that's right they're boxes in
lines as I like to um there's a a
professional small dipped to Black oath
shut up so you can even do it you can't
do it during the cut scenes you can in
Halo to so this is this is a remaster
yes the Covenant believe that what they
call the silent cartographer is
somewhere under this island the
Cartographer is a map room that will
lead us to Halo's control
center the island has multiple
structures and installations one of them
contains the M we're approaching the LZ
it's going to be hot the LZ she is hot
all right so I'm going to start off
playing but Rob and I are going to
switch off throughout the stream I've
already changed my changed it uh my
controls
to oh
there's like the timing of all this
stuff like the fact that you can't
Sprint it jumps it's like you always
have to get recalibrated to any FPS when
you switch right but uh yeah I switched
up the control scheme we'll see what you
know this is the way you want to play
but currently I've got aim on the left
trigger even though you really only aim
down sights with like two weapons in
this game um and I've got melee on the
right stick oh man uh that's very
different cuz I just like it's like
quicker as opposed to putting it on B
which is kind of where it usually is
yeah or bumper right later when do they
switch that like Halo 3 did I switch
melee to bumper I don't know so you
always play with this play you no I just
decided that it's like I've been playing
a [__] ton of Destiny lately so it's the
most Destiny esque uh so I figured it
would be the easiest
transition a I really miss those uh the
assassinations from like Halo
4 they're super good really great warks
come behind you this was so
great all right so of course uh you can
just boom Oh Oh It's instant instant
it's instant uh on the Xbox 360 version
of Halo Combat Evol anniversary was not
instant but here as you can see get a
look at the Pelican from then and
now oh yeah
mhm oh yeah can you tell which is which
I I I don't know all right you bozos
let's ride okay let's move out let's go
find the map that's I said Hal control
stealing my
lines look at that Gunner and passenger
Health meter on the top left that is
memories oh God that's
right love how the dialogue or the the
uh the lines the Marines would say are
are great they're like so reminiscent of
or Aliens 2 or aliens excuse me just
like those classic Marines the Marine
bravado yeah I'll bet the silenter
somewhere inside
that oh get
some
uhoh did we get plasma tagged I think I
think they miss uhoh and off you go
there we go come on flip it flip it in
real life that Gunner's head would have
been crushed he's got a
helmet it's
fine okay I'm going to go back in
there yes I'm taking my War hog no I
know I can drive it in
there but I feel very attached to it cuz
this was one of the greatest
Parts he just jumped off the edge and my
[__] shot him as he fell down all
right as I recall there's an invisible
guy in here F Robbie asks why we aren't
playing Co-op and we were planning on it
but I think we decided it just looks
significantly better Co-op dumbs down
the re yeah we wanted you guys to see
full screen I mean you're already
watching it kind of on a small player
like we wanted this you to
see the the graphics the game The
Covenant are putting up a real fight um
full screen so we're going to be passing
it back and forth uh maybe if we get to
like Halo 3 level or Halo 4 we can we'll
play some co-op just to mess around uh
but because this just looks so hey guys
you like a
grenade oh that's right there's a guy
with a sword right can you come down
here oh man that brings back come on
step up to the streets get see what
happens you come back oh
yeah oh that's right you go out and you
have to um go around the island go ahe I
don't remember being able to see this
guy before oh yeah he oh cuz yeah there
he is doesn't he run away no there he oh
see his sword Pro
unless system oh God it's so dark so
[__] so dark on the old school side
remember you walk out out there and
there's that one really like just really
crazy moment where you just kick like a
rock off falls
down there GNA be a lot of nostalgia all
right so I got to go back
right I'm not sure what the grenade
switch button is is it Lines no lines is
obviously
pause so yeah this is the thing that
struck me about it when I played this
for the first time is like the
architecture lines and like the kind of
the distinct sort of the corners the way
the way that this place has an alien
sort of Forerunner shape the way they
Define the forerunners through that
architecture uh it's you can see it
still here this still still the same
skeleton structure is there uh you know
of the sort of geometry of this place
but they've obviously embellished it a
lot you know there's a whole lot more
texture going on here there's a whole
lot more shapes in the newer version but
then you also have stuff like this like
that's a neat little design up there but
where does it go I mean it's it becomes
really just a real basic kind of subtle
thing up there but you know well it's a
completely different feel too
like more alien-esque colorful as
opposed to like a just basic like an
Aztec ruin type of structure M that's it
seems like your gun is really close to
that guy's head
buddy
Bo
110% this is as fast as I can do it okay
what do you I can switch back and forth
and play a little bit this way a little
bit that way we'll try to mix it up just
to uh you
know driving good at it definitely a
talented motor vehicl did you guys
die they Let's Roll come on oh get in
the car
Joo here we go here we
go Bonk H some guy says uh that door
with the elite with the SW yeah you can
actually drive the war Haw full speed
and like
skip as a glitch SK half level I guess
yeah there a into the inter of the
hello oh yeah oh Donuts of
death I remember this part cuz if you're
playing Co-op then finally whoever was
driving right you can switch over give
me one of your
guys a gun make him get out pick up some
extra Magnum
ammo oh poor oh my God that is oh he
died horribly that is a major suffering
all right yeah here he at least had the
dignity to keep his mouth
shut
Sil this the this is the
ammo I it looks pretty similar I didn't
realize it was covered in like this
plastic Oh The Blood look at the blood
on the ground very distinct splatters
just sort of the general dying of the
grass also what is this a beach now it's
grassy really white
sand almost look like uh do I have to go
up here yeah I believe so I think you're
right
yeah whoa right the environmental detail
is one area where it's hugely different
hello scared him hello friend come here
come back here I'm tap you on the back
for a job well done can't really hear my
shield indicator uh is it possible turn
TV yeah can we get a little more volume
back here guys out here on the
TV step directly on
that
oh didn't get him at all there it is
yeah come on get some oh just wanted to
show you guys the death animation there
uh you know all in the interest of the
stream and see helping you experience
Master Chief
Collection ni I feel like this zoomed in
Magnum is really
weird Dam step away from everybody
shooting me wow that was like a real
break dance situation all right let's
get more grenades what's the Halo
Trifecta it's the grenades guns and the
melee yeah
have already super low onal little
purple things exploding all over the
place let's just simplify the landscape
here a little
bit I should have waited a little longer
we're coming out here can't wait to play
all four on
legendary you solo legendary I might Sol
the legendary just as an I mean I've
done it for every game when I mean
that's just to take forever I I always
play with a buddy of mine whenever a
Halo came out we
leg oh that's my
favorite so
good work the body these guys are going
oh where'd he come from snuck around me
all right sorry guys I'll minimize the
dying now and uh continue doing some
good
jobs kind of interesting how like like
only
like sometimes will will you will they
like speak
English sometimes they yeah the little
grunts yeah they squeak
they run about all right let's do the
next
oh kind of
hurts just get this little pain back oh
God I think he run into a couple Hunters
up there yes that's true which is why I
want to preserve my Magnum ammo so
they're super
easy just plug them in the
back God damn God damn playing very
heroically and if I die one more time
I'm going to pass it off to Rob okay cuz
you know share and share
like change it up jeez I might are not
Landing I think I got stuck oh all right
take it over all right I'm going to have
to switch this
controller so yeah there's a ton of
different uh sort of settings and you
have the option to inverted God you know
you have the option to debase yourself
and play not inverted Ed um so but so
that's sh you'll
see yeah you can you have the option two
also here once you've set it um you can
press X to like set it across all games
but there are also certain but that only
works for certain settings like some are
game specific uh
controls like you know a a Halo C
control would not need to account for
um you know dual wielding
or stuff like that uh so some of them
like some of the control schemes are
marked Universal something or other like
Universal running gun Universal uh
aiming blast whatever that's a good name
for one a blast uh and those will apply
across all settings and that sort of is
just one of the ways that like they're
sort of
unifying
um you know wanted like unify your
experience across all the Halos but they
also want it to be you know they also
want to preserve the feel of the
individual ones so there's that's sort
of like the challenge I guess that 343
had when making the game and uh so far
it's going pretty good moss on the tree
switch oh my God night time some Barren
landscape night time
daytime so yeah we're playing for those
of you guys just tuning in uh little
update on what we're showing here this
is Halo Combat Evolved Anniversary as
part of the Master Chief Collection
we're able to play one level from each
of the Halo games in the Master Chief
Collection so that's the silent
cartographer from Halo Combat Evolved
that's gravemind from Halo 2 Anniversary
that's Sierra 117 from Halo 3 and uh
that's Infinity from Halo
4 so you know how to kill these guys in
one shot right one shot yeah man oh I
know the weak weak spot just get around
him get around him and shoot him right
in the back in the back it will like is
it one shot in this game try do it do it
make iten like a couple no do it just
get around back and shoot him right in
the spine sh try it oh try it try come
on get around him yeah Rodeo now just
aim right in the small of the back oh no
maybe they have an extra P there I don't
think come on just do
it Shu and move Bob and we oh there's
two what it wasn't really one they
changed that later on I had to have I
had to have I do not remember being that
Easy E fritzy in the twitch chat we will
check out the terminal in a second
uh but we're just going to let Rob take
care of these Hunters with the one shot
to the small of the back boom I don't
remember that that's insane insane we
used to take like forever on this I know
as long as you have the Magnum you can
just
freaking so
good all right so before you go out of
here head back down into the little
Basin area when Halo Combat Evolved
Anniversary came out they added these
things called terminals stop right there
before you get the overshield just look
no no uh back up a little bit and look
at this wall to your left back up now
now switch terminals are these little
stations that appeared in the uh
anniversary in the remastered Edition
and if you go up to it you can interact
with it uh oh good freaking me up and
press X to use it and then it will uh
give press or hold it literally just
says press X to use terminal oh whoa
press X to go to Xbox
store okay so the the terminal takes you
to a Halo Channel thing now I guess uh
because basically what they did was
these terminals gave you extra
information extra Video Extra assets
about uh what the game
um you know about Halo and the Halo
Universe uh so we're not GNA worry about
downloading this stuff now so it would
kind of like dwell into like where you
were yeah like you know like this
location that you know and if you find
it then you can access it from the menu
as well um I I don't remember exactly
what they were all about I think that
they were sort of lore based stuff
um and yeah it it it was it's pretty
neat so you definitely going to you know
you want you're going to want to get
that set up once you if you like get
into this but we're not going to delve
too far into that right
now oh I should have got an overshield
IDI only there was a way to literally
walk back there too and get it it's too
late we must Forge
onward oh
this oh you idiot that was seriously
like a 10-year-old Rob right there look
at his but head smack I just feel 13 all
over
again that was
good did you ever used to uh do the
grenade thing where you just keep
killing your buddy and Co-op until you
drop nades and drop nades and drop nades
like next to a warhog yep that was we
did that a bunch oh yeah that was like
part of the game was like just getting
like with your buddy and just doing
stupid [__] and messing around because
like the the vehicle stuff the kind of
the space of in these these environments
the this was as a first-person shooter
on Console it wasn't just you know I
mean there was a lot about it that felt
new and fresh and like sandboxy almost
you know it wouldn't count as a it
doesn't really qualify as a Sandbox in
the way we use the term today but the
way that these spaces were the way that
these combat areas were you know it was
it felt that way
right in the back one and done baby so
my first
experience whoa
Olay my first Halo experience was like
my buddy was like oh yeah come over play
game Halo with you know the first
controllers that were the big bulky ones
the Duke the Dukes
um and then he we played uh I think it's
called two betrayals I think is the map
where like you start off in ghosts or no
banshees and he's like follow me we get
the Banshees and we go inside and the H
to huge drop let's see this thing look
what it looks like now and then oh for
sure oh actually they basically use like
the same thing for the model got a
little lazy
there they're like hey man it works
sorry you're saying the the Banshee
situation so he's like okay go to the
bottom of this area you go all the
bottom and he goes all the top and he
just ejects and we did this for like
three hours was watch our bodies fall
and just land on on he's like is that
great and we just
like now it would just not be enjoyable
but it just goes to show like that game
was just oh please like it was only a
few years ago here in the games spot
offices where we were playing Saints Row
three or two and literally Shawn
mckinness just spent three hours
standing on the boardwalk chucking
people into the river and trying to get
their heads to bang on the guard on the
railing as they went over it's just fun
it
is it's so different our oh yeah
oh oh no I should have killed him I
always do that oh guys are cloaked look
at that cloaking it's so like shiny
oh guys look you came out of
shower that's what cloak delites are
they're just
clean get a
towel how do you switch grenade
d-pad left and right uh we have a
different oh light you get a freaking
light I remember that uh going to we're
going to go ahead and look in the chat
at twitch.tv/ Gamespot or in the
Gamespot comments and take questions
about this stuff I mean uh we have this
we have an early copy
of the Master Chief collection and we're
playing through specific levels that 343
Industries has is allowing us to to play
through uh for live stream purposes so
we can't play other levels uh we've
we've only got one per game so this is
the silent cartographer in Combat
Evolved Anniversary we can't play
multiplayer at all either or even really
check it out um because that's they're
like it's embargoed and that's the terms
of the agreement so uh can't answer
every question but we can answer some so
for
example uh can you switch Graphics mid
cinematic e fritzy wonders you can't in
annivers in Combat Evolved but you can
in Hal
yeah I was watching the intro one to the
Grave level we're going to be playing in
just a bit uh and it's very different
like it's cu the they they do different
camera shots blur Studios actually did
the uh the cut scenes they did the one
the cut scenes for um Halo 4 which were
so good um give you chill and the the
new ones for Halo 2o and the trailer was
released this morning um they did all
that stuff and they they changed camera
like some of them are the same the
dialogue overlaps I think is mostly the
same the dialogue um but like I think
they re-recorded some dialogue I sure I
bet they I think they did re-record but
uh in terms of like the lines of
dialogue I think they say the same lines
whereas they don't always use the same
camera angles in the you know visually
yeah um
so that's to answer your question mhm
bet those two marines are still in the
warhog chilling having
combo can we show Forge KAC no again
this live stream we can only show four
levels have you seen we're on the first
you seen some of the forge uh no so
tight I've not checked it out did you
get to check it out at a preview event
or something no uh I just saw a video
online and it was like they they do
basically as opposed to like starting
off on a blank M map you can like start
off on like just water and really get
down to like fresh clean slate and build
anything like multiple Islands
it looked really tight
mhm um
nice all right so now you got to go oh
yeah switch it up that purple
spray oh
Sho my
car what are you doing to your ride is
this dude probably your sou come
here
alone
now fgg Galaxy can you play the other
levels and not show them uh
yes yes I can yeah all the campaigns are
are unlocked all the levels are unlocked
I so I will be doing that uh in lead up
to the review but we can only live
stream one level per per Halo and uh
this is Combat Evolved Anniversary
obviously the silent cartographer and
then look at these bozos just like
hanging out oh did you did you want us
to like we there oh did we we just all
right I'll I'll come we were just
supposed to land that's all we know no
one said anything about like following
you
guys that was always fun coming back to
there and always picking up new guys
always like new fod always were like
damn I lost a dude I need him to be in
there so I can like park next to an
enemy for long minutes and he can shoot
it
laboriously yeah there you go dude this
game still looks so good like what do
you mean by so good well like this is
playable to me so good and playable are
a long way off from each other off I
don't know it just was so long ago it's
just you oh
almost can you kill these Hunters
without getting totally blown up do
it got to work that fish tail oh took
one to the side oh Gunner's not doing so
good they jump like butt heads they did
oh I mean if you you're in a bad spot oh
God and we're done your Shields are down
oh I forgot I had
this that's also a pretty oh hello I
know you around here please just don't
blow yourself up with a rocket is he
dead I think the one guy is but there's
there are
two
you leave him alone you got his back I
wish this dud would follow you around oh
yeah I guess you did you must have run
over that other guy cool oh I think now
we'll uh see the elite sword guy
whoa that was weird I feel like you
switched it back right when your Shield
was or checkpoint yeah
weird all right this guy's going to eat
a freaking
rocket oh he's gone where is he I forgot
about that oh we're going see this cool
moment
shafted so yeah this is uh the new
remastered version of the cut scene you
can't switch right no I am trying to
switch can't you can't switch between
cut scenes as we mentioned before but
you can in Halo 2 which will happen soon
oh he kick someone else this time what'd
he kick just a little thing just some
little junk all right let's check this
out do the switch r on this thing
Perfecto zero says I thought he was in
nextg the whole time until we
switched yeah I mean the design of oh
wow that's
cool the like artistic design really
holds up and I think it's an interesting
way in anniversary to uh think
about art in the game and like what
technical design is and what artistic
design is or like what sort of sort of
uh I don't know I guess I'm not really
saying it super well but like the the
sort of architecture of it the the feel
of the space like that stuff largely a
lot of that translates and that's a
testament to the designers of the
original game uh at Bungie and how well
they did it but then the remastering oh
hello friend look at him he's out he's
on his computer he's checking his
Covenant he's checking his Jihad email
look at you just waiting damn it wanted
to punch his butt
oh all right come on can you get two
for
nope right too close too close all right
let's try this again Should I stick
him should I punch
him all right galaxy has a question how
are they sinking the two games like this
so here's the
deal the game we're playing is called
Halo Master Chief Collection within Halo
Master Chief Collection are four Halo
games Halo Combat Evolved Anniversary
Halo 2 Anniversary Halo 3 and Halo 4 in
the anniversary games what that
anniversary means is they are remasters
of the Xbox games they didn't remaster
the Xbox 360 games CU they're already in
HD uh it means that they you can switch
between and one of the features of these
anniversary games is you can switch
between the remastered visuals and the
old ones with the Press of a button Rob
please demonstrate ta and it's just like
that when you play it when Halo Combat
Evolved Anniversary came out on the 360
the switch took like two seconds it
would go to black and it would come up
but thanks to the power of the Xbox One
it happens immediately so it's all good
um so this is actually the same game
we're playing we're playing a level from
Halo Combat Evolved Anniversary and just
tapping the button to switch between the
looks of the two the enemies are in the
same places it's just a visual change uh
everything else is is the
same oh Jackal eat it so hopefully that
uh explains to yeah pretty
well we can to play every level the
whole way through uh I don't know it's
like 2:30 now yeah maybe we should yeah
maybe we should switch it up uh the only
the reason to play all the way through
is
weop we are allowed to show the uh
cutscenes at the beginning and the end
from the games but then again Halo
anniversary has been out for many years
and so the revamped cutscene stuff uh
is like you guys could have seen it
before pretty easily but this level's
almost over right yes I actually don't
remember when it ends uh no it is this
is like the last trashing you um you get
the you get you get you go down in here
you pick up the Cartographer and then
you come back up and then you're good to
go the Pelican takes you off
but should we BCE out of
this uh we're going to call a vote in
the chat keep going yes uh move on or
stick it through uh finish level or skip
finish or skip finish or skip just let
us
know finish or
skip uh B in the gam spot comments wants
to know what difficulty we're playing on
this is heroic with no
out re was the brightness on OG Halo
always so low Bas I guess it was it was
pretty low okay it looks like skip
carries it in the twitch chat so let's
go ahead and quit uh just do all right
so we're just gonna go ahead and save
quit out of the sound cartographer it's
GNA save our checkpoint here and we're
going to go into Halo 2 so yeah Skip by
a long shot yeah so we're going to go to
Halo 2 and you guys are going to get to
see the intro cut scene for the gravem
level which is when you really get up
close and personal with the grave mind
now I've watched this already Rob hasn't
uh to my knowledge and it's it's pretty
freaking cool yeah when I saw um when I
did like the preview event we I got to
see one of the cut scenes full length
there was one where you come in in Halo
2 you come in on a um like the orbital
drop and you come out with the rocket
launcher it was that whole cut scene and
it like literally gave me hairs like my
or my it grew hair on rob it grew hair
that began a very special time in his
life down here lots of strange feelings
that you never had before I freaked out
uh so yeah again you can switch through
the campaigns just like this all the
missions are unlocked as you can see uh
just right from the get-go and then you
can you can make like playlists of
different missions they've obviously set
up playlists for each of the games in
their entirety and then a cross game
playlist there's multiplayer which we
can't show today it's not even really in
there yet uh so we're going to go to
Halo 2 yeah we are and we're going to
play
gravemind so blur did the intro for Halo
4 too right I'm assum I'm assuming you
know yeah yeah which that would was
awesome all right I'm going to put this
on normal because I tried playing this
on heroic in the first room I got my
butt kicked it was vicious oh Halo 2 was
really tough and so the there's a ton
more skulls if you were watching earlier
in the Stream you saw there was only
like seven scoring skulls and two
non-scoring skulls but then here we go
we've got like profit birthday party
we've got oh tons every you've got your
rare combat dialogue becomes more common
all player held weapons fire Scarab gun
beams like this stuff is weird AI no
longer Flinch from attacks Chief trades
his flashlight for active camo and then
of course the scoring multipliers which
uh there are many
of what does this say flood combat forms
spawned by infection forms reanimated
corpse are much more dangerous like
upgrades the rank of most enemies all
this stuff gnarly uh we're not doing any
of that stuff right now cuz we want to
just show you guys the the the game in
action did you turn a couple huh did you
turn on a couple I don't think so oh I
did yeah yeah yeah no oh these were on
before I put them it was like dude
Scarab gun like the like so charge up
beam thing is it wait what's the Scarab
gun oh the Scarab is the Walker oh so
it's like the
most crazy that is crazy I guess want to
see that all
right all right guys here comes the
grave mind oh damn so they changed the
so he's like a more of a snake you're
looking dude just shut up just
enjoy oh my God it's so good feed me see
more dude oh he's so gross
all right damn this is Halo 2
Anniversary the grave mind level your
first look at this
slimy crazy
creature
remastered what is that
I I am among
to all your
sins all right I won't do this too often
during this thing but you can
switch oh my God this is what the grave
mine looks like Halo 2
Styles this one is Miss oh he is so
gross and has it mind concluded
this one is but flesh and faith and is
the more
deluded kill me or Release Me
parasite but do not waste my time with
talk there is
much and I have listened through Rock
and metal and
time now I shall talk and you shall
listen greetings I am 2401 penitent
tangent I am the monitor of
install it just like
rescs
counil and so it's like this one runs a
little ahead of the last one we are to
control this out stay where you are
nothing can be done until my sermon is
complete
not true this installation has a
successful U 1.2 trillion simulated in
one actual it is ready to fire on demand
of all the objects our Lords left behind
there are none so worthless as these
oracles they know nothing of the great
Jour and you know nothing about
containment you have demonstrated
complete disregard for even the most
basic protocols this one's
containment
and this one's great journey are the
same it just looks so weird all right
I'm switch profets have this like this
mouth was just really confusing promised
you freedom from a doomed
existence but you will find no salvation
on this ring he's actually speaking
through the second mouth yeah yeah he's
way back the throat not do not mistake
very intent or all will this thing is
Right Halo is a weapon your prophets are
making a big mistake your ignorance
already destroyed one of the sacet Rings
demon it shall not harm another if you
will not heal the truth then I will show
it to
you there is still time to stop the key
from
turning but first it must be found just
te on
search one likely spot and you will
search another fate have us meet as
fools but this ring will make us
Brothers oh right so this is where he
Wars
to oh God keeps going oh yeah can't wait
someone cuts all these scenes and puts
them on
YouTube
I think you're I probably might do that
it's good point uh so this is it it
froze at this point when I was watching
it before it'll catch up in just a
second but just a reminder this is
pre-release there are patches coming for
this
code this thing actually happened relas
of the parasite was unexpected
unfortunate but there is no need to
panic like look at this
room there is no
there is a time to Rejoice a moment that
all the come on man you're there stop
watching them on TV
a the great journey is nigh and nothing
not even the flood can stop
it did that happen kill the
demon kill the demon oh it's tight
oh mama okay uh I got to switch the
settings real
quick Universal oh so it's so actually
so see now it's set on universal zoomo
because I had set these as a through
line for all the games wow so it's back
to my preferred settings you'll have to
switch when I pass it back to you
whatever Needler hello fter you can kill
those bres the
better yeah thanks cordana thanks for
the pro tip
I didn't know at this point they don't
have Shield generators but take them out
before it's berserking it's
berserking oh there's going to be some
great visuals to switch back and forth
to on this
one so yeah this
is
D the demon has infiltrated the council
chamber protect the hierarch
where's your oh I don't think so where's
the other PL wait is which this is
original no oh God I got like Sidetrack
for a second I was like yeah yeah so
we've got that boom and again the
switching this is Halo 2 Anniversary uh
so this has not been available before
this is only going to be as part of
the uh Master
collection
oh yeah give me that tutorial notice oh
my gosh I think I know at this point I
played
this I guess I mean I'm playing this on
normal cuz honestly I was playing it
before on hard and getting totally
rocked and I didn't want you guys to
watch that no exactly someone in this
chat was just like this was so hard on
legendary far was yeah so
difficult a
fre I pick up a grenade yet no I don't
think oh yeah there's more guys even
that come out on heroic look at one of
their uh bodies and do the switch okay
hold on there's I think there's another
en their dead bodies and switch up
what's up
buddy whoa look at that
he's just sliding
off hello dead grunt look at that hair
yeah it's gone it's a hairy beast not
even even there let's check out his butt
that butt that is a nice remastered butt
feel like it's not even there where did
his butt go got less of a butt maybe
it's just it we'll have to do it on a
live specimen oh here we go oh look at
this guy
yep Alo his his head has hair this guy's
got hair he's got hair kind of oh look
at those teeth though damn oh
crap dude give us a sec come on I'm just
investigating your dead
friend it's not weird
okay whoa carbine switch that want to
see the carbine
yeah go [__] sick m i mean we've seen
carbine more recently right in uh all
right where am I going something
pedestal near the door did she
say go down
there what do you want from me
cordana they've locked it from below
there's a door at the other end of the
chamber cool cool
great new old remaster oh the the D
plasma weapons look so much cool they do
so
shiny
truth he has the index you've got to
take it from him what's up cordana let
me get these
doors go it'll be easier to track truth
if I stay in the
network mhm so she's not like they
didn't go full uh like Halo 4 c
l oh God
uhoh her uh her cheeks f a little
puy look man it's just those it's those
Covenant systems they always add 10
lbs oh yeah this
music old
Styles go away from that turret give me
that turret like
a I recently I don't think I can break
it off no you can't you can't um I
recently went back and watched like
remember like the E3 Halo 2 like demo
live demo they it they showed off
Halo to and like with the crowd you hear
the crowd just freaking out over certain
things like when he gets on a turret
yeah when he when he uh dual wiels when
he it was just so gave me chills just CU
I remember watching that like i k fre
out oh hello speaking freaking
out did you say yeah oh yeah
yeah this guy loves
it po a power smash a
back I'm coming out of the got here for
sure I'm talking about get where where
this guy is like Jack up he's berserking
man's he's
berserking all
right damn
yeah the city get closer for the city oh
yeah
whoa
you guys got to need
questions let us know I'm sure Chris can
answer
them only do so
much chat is arguing what
1080p whether it's HD or not great super
a fun conversation that everyone always
enjoys everyone oh man
BL oh he's got the brute shot oh that's
right I want to see that I want to see
everything show it all to me show it all
the BL but the blade looks a little
different probably not actually where we
go where go where we go buddy come on
come on oh god there it is I got it it's
cool sick oh look at this city that's so
sick
H still looks pretty cool but I mean
it's no that what was that shrieking
thing these oh yeah Birds the hell
seagull just
seagull how these seagull these are some
anniversary SE level seagulls y'all they
are very right what who is doing that
a TR is moving through the lower levels
of the tower I'll reverse this grab LIF
she's a heavy
eater man she's a she's a soldier all
right she where I start getting
teleported every which way all the time
should I did she me step in there I
wasn't paying attention to her after
that stunt on the Cairo I know you're
not afraid of heights yeah you just jump
down I think it's just like it's like a
lift It'll like catch your fall she
going to say something more that's it
she she was just basically talking [__]
yeah she was H love Cortana h look at
that hello nice nice shot that's good 10
years ago
Cortana you look great babe she's like
take your time it's
fine where this guy just freaking go
already why does he keep looking at me
all
right yep haircuts pretty much the same
although yeah a little more pronounced
on the bang situation
MH so you can also hear the music track
change right or is it just out of
syn like it's way more
predominant yeah I kind of agree I kind
of think she looks better
before okay see you later
woo oh yeah oh look at this graceful
fall
probably
guys I think he had a beam
rifle yeah sure check that out maybe
I'll that do the switch with the beam
rifle all right all right this is what
what go away go off the ledge dude these
rifles are
nasty go oh do the switch when he falls
where'd he
go
whoa where are some more corpses I can
push over the edge
you
oh oh right in the butt oh he loves that
he's in look at him it's just see you oh
I'm coming I'm coming I can't see my
leg well do the switch kind of a
difference here little bit of a
difference step in okay
carry
on wants to get beamed beamed oh switch
itfor
wow that beam rifle got real gnarly s
got like five more L I can't jump that
they beeping up their Patrols stay sharp
thanks thanks
babe hit him that guy just
launched the grunt Shield a grunt what's
it called Brute shot brute shot shot the
shield hello
friend I think he saw you at the last
second what's going on over there oh God
uh
oh
two time two
time switch
it love it whoa just come over here and
step on that okay
f uhoh uhoh a situation here Retreat
okay so the only difference with Halo 3
if iall correctly is just the frame rate
and they they just bumped up Halo 3 to
60 want to punch fight with Chief it's a
bad idea okay yeah it's a giant gorilla
you shouldn't really do that shouldn't
really punch fight the
chief cool if you just ripped your arms
off hi guys Shields they do
nothing where's my guy oh put that
down and I do uh hit melee now with the
uh boot shot I want to see the blade The
Brute shot the blade of the brute shot
all right get into a better lit area oh
right a
two it's like a little it's weird how
like sometimes like anniversary is
darker and sometimes uh original is
darker I feel like there's not like a
whole lot of like it it
varies ni he's just just do it there
this is I guess this is happening
now I guess I'll just do
nothing
oh oh this is
quick oh
nice just yelling so
much
yeah like in this part it's really easy
to see him the old one and really hard
whoa look like the Miss on the
ground Miss no no Miss
there which one am I out of ammo for
where's the thing give me the thing
there was a weapon yes there
is oh hey
buddy and I wish play another level
play the whole game the whole Halo 2
situation yeah it's all that's what
you're saying yeah remind the folks
while we can't we are only allowed to be
showing this level so yeah that's what
we're going to be doing unforunately
only this level from Halo 2 Anniversary
one level per game it's nap
time quiet everything's fine go to sleep
forever na in your little
Corners oh oh
butts hello come here get I really want
to thank
you know you
are flail on the Dead one as
well God grunt smashing old Styles grun
smashing oh wow
stick you on the crotch dang it
oh ouch Burns took it oh he's
berserking rubs got to get out of here
the last guy oh oh he berserked me right
in the
butt you want to play sure all
right switching it up switch it
up
and we're
good oh so this so
default interesting enough goes back to
uh B
melee yeah but in uh CE it was bum oh
interesting really yeah what in CE there
were no
bumpers what am I doing here uh oh he's
coming and I guess there were no bumpers
on this one
either
uhoh oh look at
assle come to
Mama giant gorilla men what are you
going to do what are you going to
do escape from the
zoo two for
one can you twer on the beam rifle you
can think I believe in you and I believe
you also I'm going dual
wield oh yeah du plazy going this way
right Which Way littered with dead
bodies should you go oh there she is
there's my babe there's in the next
girl
uhoh
it is intense oh I remember this level
so much now is it all coming back to you
now Gran you do like one huge you charge
them both up you do one huge one did you
do a mega Mega Blast a mega Char monster
Plasma Pistol thing we got
here the old brute
plazas oh yeah oh I think these wi the a
for most improved weapon uh visually
speaking
Yeah
I don't know if I ever actually noticed
that the like uh blue the purple sort of
arc on the side the arc the design on
the side of the barrel like increases
with as a it's like a heat meter oh is
it yeah you're totally right I don't
know if I noticed that I don't know if I
ever noticed that that's tight I
actually didn't hey man noticing
stuff Soul crazy J how much space will
the Master Chief Collection take up on
my hard drive I think that I have
downloaded 45 GB yeah ranilla got it 45
GB plus a 20 gab
update that's a lot of
gigabytes ah I blew
it you're out of ammo for the Beamer
oh can we see the can we do a little
needlers switches let's let's just check
out some needlers now and then needlers
oh I really like how they I don't know
which do you prefer like cuz there's
these are sort of like Jagged like
dagger like like obsidian dagger kind of
thing and these are like crystals right
I don't
know oh he got caught
looking rubber neck back here God damn
it
stupid
y Corin Lin observing that it must suck
to be a grunt you're the Expendable
crewmen there's no chance of survival
this guy just did like a
cartwheel that was funny that's the
power of the chief
yeah the grunts to have it rough I mean
they they die really easily they do get
to have birthday parties like a lot so I
guess that's that's how they keep morale
up
but oh Dom
skis you you know what I am having a
memory of this this this area right well
on legendary oh it was so tough I'm
having
like Chief in whoops okay
where did I get went up into the center
area I guess here Chief wasn't that fun
want to do it again here Chief go for a
ride you ever been on an elevator before
it's
Neato oh
gu hello friend come on I
thought this guy's confused about his
life and his job he probably really
liked me man what the heck man how'd you
get up there did you get to use that
elevator thing that was dope as hell you
never get to do that
man oh
okay hey what's up oh that was an energy
sword that you can't use whoa that is
different trippy just switch it yeah I
always do
this
neet God damn it's quietly she
said oh this is always oh hi what's up
are you going to actually kill someone
from behind for once in your life yeah
just saying I feel like many times on
this stream you've just been watching
them and then they they're like what the
hell and you're like oh dang it I wanted
to kill it from behind oh come
on wonder what the Arbiter is doing
right now where where does he uh send
you forget I'm sorry when is he where
does the grave M am I the Arbiter now
yeah you are do he am I the Arbiter of
this relationship Rob definitely are all
right that's fine I'm okay with that
Arbiter was is pretty badass bad uh very
S I think he sends you to um the ring
with a buch where like you made up with
stars and stuff
I yeah and you're but we and yeah we can
watch the cut scene after this uh oh we
watch cut scenes yes cool we allowed
watch the cut scenes before and after
the levels so nice uh but once the the
next level cut scene starts up we're
going to have to stop it um also going
to have to oh yeah all
these all these multi-level elevators
cuz there's low there's a level below
this that you can go one of those
elevators is down you just came
from oh do you want to carabine some
people from up
here oh yeah shoot him in their hand
hand hand head hand head what oh from
downtown sorry
downstairs oh cool I'm here that's yeah
uh checkpoint awareness and management
was such a huge it's such a huge deal
when you play this on legendary yeah cuz
you like bust your ass to get through
these sections and then right you can
get set
back let's try this again
oh nated how could I not invite you to
this we're saving you for the launch
stream man hopefully Nat's in the twitch
chat I know you're a Halo
guy I think we're going to try to do
some uh some legendary streaming some
multiplayer streaming and stuff as the
uh release date for The Master Chief
Collection gets closer oh nice so yeah
you know false on Twitter and all that
to uh figure that stuff out boom all the
grunts this is like in legendary it was
like if if you woke up someone by
accident you would just start over you
would like get as many dudes as possible
as they're
sleeping you just got them all think I
did what up
dudes nice jump that dude's got up he is
excited going
it
run my babies don't worry guys we're all
going to get out of here alive wink wink
I
promise you guys know how to use an
elevator
right are you just following this person
they know to go I
guess yeah just a human I'm just a human
I'm just a human you go first freaking
super
soldier let's see this guy then and now
oh oh we scared him all dude it's all
right we laughed at his face come on
that was
rude they always run away they are
really self-conscious about how they
used to look that's look at me like this
oh where are these dudes behind you
there's one I
think
hello would like to get needled death by
a thousand
needles oh you need both oh you want to
you want a hold clip you I guess you
want to get a whole
bunch ah I love it when they Dodge roll
off of surfaces and Plum it to their
deaths it's
great
Jesus jackal
oh just keep going
up
sure up and out
maybe I can't
recall yeah they're going up you're
going
up that's why you need them around
they're the brains of the operation
clear you're just the muscle show me
where to
go I will shoot it I'm going shoot it
this is
right as long as there continue being
guys for you to
shoot is there a checkpoint anywhere
supposed to go back
down let's look for Cortana there she is
go down down one level one
level
okay living on the edge than
Bab
hey oh yeah they're not oblivious to
your presence
here get
it needles to the Dome they were just
parking on his head like a two just
everyone wonder what that would feel
like probably not to get needled get
needled yeah be excruciatingly painful
look at those things either one of them
which one would you would you want would
I want to die by yeah these guys I feel
like I would want to die by the jagged
ones because they're pointier and they
would go in deeper quicker those like
just punch a giant hole in you I mean
this is this is the other end of them
probably right think about the logistics
of those needles that they like go down
and through I don't know get out of the
we came in theal gra all right go back
to the central grav lift all right those
needles are just so beautiful all right
beautiful needles so now you guys don't
even know where you're going now we're
going back
up yeah let's speed through
this
rein
okay
GG thanks thanks for the heads up
appreciate it thanks for the Intel
appreciate it C oh you're
done you're done [__]
accuracy anyone else yeah what's up yeah
it's got to be a big
guy that's adorable
uh oh he's
got oh I want that get it I want to see
what this looks like no no it's not it
where is it not picking it
up land on his head God damn
it can you pick up the grunt launchers
in
this oh well I guess it depends was that
L that's it right there isn't that it
right on the ground look down or don't
get
berserker you're done you just look on
that other ramp one
sec hey you get away from him he took
care of business he's fine they're doing
fine now only one that
survived don't don't walk off the edge
and die or
anything I will [__] that guy all right
where are we looking at that oh maybe he
just had the uh I think he was going to
set that up I think that's it's a
Deployable turet
okay old old
new my
brother me likey it was T and the
m m
that flow though little electrical
current that kind of yeah flowing out to
the to the tip well those guys literally
just appear Elites I thought you guys
had uh got fired you guys all got fired
a bunch of unemployed Elites just
running around here no don't say
that I have marketable skills what are
those guys called uh drones dick holes
dick holes that's right that's that's it
canonical look they're fighting oh
that's right is this the uh the
uprising you're
done my
sword oh what is that noise that sounds
they definitely revamped like sound
effects can you switch it
again oh that sounds cool do it
again pretty
cool hey where you go hey I saw you over
there swirly little bastard
those dudes were so tough in legendary
like when you're on Cairo station and
they come up remember that they just
like all like all them at once they'll
just ruin your
day
oh whoa dude they're buzzing the tower
man buzzing the
tower they're called drones right if
maybe chat would know I think they're
called drones let's find out flying
dudes Halo
to drones I
believe the
Yan oh they got
their genius class name
yep drones aren't Brave they're just
incapable of feeling fear according to
to bungie.net description of drones
that's a little terrifying I got that
off the Halo wikia they don't
fear whoa they
don't
there oh look at that party over
there they're kill that's right yeah the
prophet starts talking hell of [__]
about the elites you guys hear that he
is talking [__] is he is he talking
about us did you say we failed oh hell
man I gave my life to this
dude this
[__] that was a for benefits
November that was a really cool of You
by the
way I think you can do the same trick
with the carbine to the back I'm not
sure
mama I love this music we're just gets
kind of
like Pokey I don't know the music is so
strange yeah there's one song it's like
relaxed a little
bit one song I like this is definitely
going to go well for you is not going to
work
uhuh see yeah in Halo to they take way
more
shots well I think it's just a pistol
man the Magnum on Hal in Halo there's no
yeah Magnum is so bad it's like all you
needed just three shots
multi oh my God it's like you're gently
patting his
head good girl can you just run by these
two
dudes you would
chop chooo it's like oh yeah let's see
if I can massage the
lumbar see you
my oh oh dude I killed him and then he
was swinging at The Brute oh damn yeah
you just lunged right into that damn oh
nasty all right I'm run by these guys
again that sound effect is so
cool right in the butt
hey it's their weak
spot guing the groups now
lead they ask for your legance and you
shall give
it you shall give
itess
never you on the outside you're just
going to stand there while the snipers
are sniping oh yeah these guys are badly
good yeah head on a swivel oh my God can
you just go down
there and like do some switching
between again folks this is Halo 2
Anniversary part of the Master Chief
collection and uh we're playing the
grave M
level hello friend oh he shed it on you
uh and like with Halo Combat Evolved
Anniversary you can switch between the
original visuals and the remastered
visuals with the mere press of a button
uh we playing on Xbox one obviously the
only system that Master Chief
collection's coming out
for I'm Chris Waters and this is Rob
Handler currently uh shooting shooting
the dudes currently
shooting yeah y ammo up this was the
first weapon get a look at the sky can
we get like some absolutely press some
uh maybe there's maybe just move now cuz
the bad guy's like right near
you yeah he's right over there to the
right he's camouflaged shut up oh my God
I didn't I told you he's he's like
hanging out inside all that grass all
right can you like look up at the big
disc thing to the
right yeah show me
that show me some switch
Rosies oh CL
Offroad terrain here we go this is fine
the developer definitely intended for me
to go here oh this is be good here we go
oo cool cool cool design of the the ark
right that's what it's called The Arc
that's the arc is in Halo 3 as I recall
uh that's what's underground no it's
like the huge place out in space that
can control all the Halos oh right
you're
right okay so I'm going where Maybe over
back that door that you just came up
this no not that way the left yeah maybe
over there I just
fall something Zing you oh yeah there's
a door you twisted your ankle okay oh
God but okay your anle Shield came back
here we go theen just destroyed two of
their own ships and I'm heing reports of
small ARS their dude there pillars were
there pill of the Cen the path is Broad
and we shall walk ins side Civil
War the Elite's getting hella pissed
rupture it's in
Amber
oh oh that's your boys hey guys you want
to come over here please can I get a
pick up can I get a
lift you're first you're first I think
someone's sniping you from behind oh
behind yep you're
right that Beamer
the beam
skis dizzy ghost in the twitch chat it
keeps switching because this is Halo 2
Anniversary and we can do that with the
Press of a button switch between the old
and the new and we switched to show you
the differences and because it's it's
pretty cool that pretty
cool the music is so talk about
Ral
yeah
right all to the
face hello friend is that a grunt
wearing the Elite's hat you look
ridiculous it fits me I
swear I'm not
fair stupid little flag whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa that is you sinking
up your woses with the beeping of your
Shield whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa this way there shooting at me oh
there he
is Mo in Moi in the twitch chat in CE
Anniversary it did load when it changed
on the 360 uh there was like it went
black for a few seconds and then came
back up with the new ones but now it's
instantaneous
much to the Delight of many and the
chrin of some we'll try to keep this
switching to like judicious times but
this and we'll stay we'll stay on some
new
Biz
whoa
different just call it out call like I
see it
different
hello
what near that explosion friend This
Grass different
different oh there's like moss on the
Rocks nice
touch that's a it's probably a
completely different type of rock yeah
they got a new species of rock in it's
great yeah this modeled it after some
new rocks this new kind of rock they
discovered in the past 10 years came out
more a granite
type do like this is like an what is
this like a Zen Garden or something like
what oh you got plumbed
go play no oh
good do it air ball that
one Everybody Must Get
explode uh-oh
right in the hairy tokus those
guys I get to the next cut
scene so you can still use the sword
just the uh
handle these guys just need to do the
handle guys just need to like you know
fight themselves you guys seem like
you're working through some isues I
don't want to get in the way of the
process figure it out no don't worry
about me I'll see you
later just going to keep on keeping on
uhoh he he yelled
sorry oh these guys just just just keep
spinning around and looking hell of
confused
oh oh he chopped his head off go go go
go
uhoh quick shoot
him you just throw a grenade at
him that was weird that was little
weird questionable switch sometimes it
like does it's
like distance lunge lunge get that
lunge
metome just going to keep going just
forge
onward from the
hey that look like like a uh oh he's
berserking he's
berserking these levels are long yeah
they are so this is Halo 2 uh
anniversary in the Master Chief
Collection we're allowed to show a level
from each of the Halos we showed one the
silent cartographer from a Halo Combat
Evolved earlier and uh before the
stream's out we're going to show you a
little glimpse of Halo 3 in action and
also a taste of Halo 4 but not too long
cuz Halo 4 is going to be I don't know
pretty much sameish yeah I we're sort of
emphasizing the Halo 2 situation but
we're almost at the end of this level we
wanted to get to the end of this level
cuz we're also allowed to show you guys
though we can't show you guys any other
levels from uh Halo 2 Anniversary it's
kind of First Look at stream well I
don't know if it's the first one but
it's kind of the first time we've had it
in house to get like get some time with
it stream through take questions about
it so we're spending extra time here and
then we're going to see whatever cut
scene comes at the end of this mission
and uh then move on to the next one
because the new cutscenes from blur
Studios uh were the ones who developed
them with 343 are freaking cool they're
freaking
cool not annoying right yeah that's
super fun for
everyone uh-oh whoa Nice Shot splashing
it on the face take it to the do oh yeah
the old shooting off his skull
cap love that
hat there's always the last dude he's
like all right you want to go mess up my
friends I didn't want to do this when
they were around it's kind of
embarrassing
but it's really degrading to go in all
Forest no one wants to do it when anyone
else is doing it but they all really
just want to do it not they not when
they're watching
I feel like whoa now like done a full
loop and seen all of this before I know
right total
repeat that doesn't get old that was a
good death whale does not get old say
what you want to about these a-hole
aliens on a Jihad across the Galaxy
let's Che some water they've got some
death whales leave them alone they're
just grunts
sorry I didn't mean he's using the sword
butt this basically like you picked up a
piece of garbage off the ground and are
just starting to hit people with it see
this water how they
fight different oh my
god wow look look the like frame rates
yeah it's slowing down a little bit too
much
AAA okay
what h
H this up get there going right way no
no uhoh that guy has an SW word yeah he
does oh always he's on your
tail
yes this really hurts I think that is
the closest approximation of what I
would do if someone stuck an explosive
to my
head and then oh God it's so
frustrating I think I'm going up uhoh
look at all those guys you can see your
swords
idiot maybe you should have turned off
the SW
word step directly on that damn damn
it I think this where you came out no
okay yeah if there was a grun it was on
the right yeah there was a grunt inside
then you probably didn't come out there
oh this guy just unpr urbed entirely by
what's going on outside turns it on oh
his his spider sense is tingling oh
that's
right already freezing out easy grunt
just take it easy everything's going to
be fine why don't you have a you
just oh look at him they were like all
standing really
close I don't even have to kill them I
guess but I will oh here we go new
weapon oh mama fuel Rod
Cannon is different it looks like a
giant alligator
head I can take
one these are the old timey
graphs
oh
[__] blow it
up see you
guys how very kind of you to present
that to me oh take a little off the
top your shielding on your turret is
insufficient oh mama whoa where you hey
buddy how's it going want to get roded
Rod that was
Rod
uh put that grenade right in the
mix look at all these individuals oh hey
guys they're so
angry wow that would
easy move along sir all right
do you think we're almost at the end of
this level I think we're close come on
CNE maybe does chat know this looks kind
of can we just like show the next level
just run by all these guys portana said
you might consider sitting this one out
I hardly agree just do a pull an end
around oh they're fighting behind those
let
goo and uh go N I got to kill him you
sure
yeah
I feel like red doors have opened up for
you
before okay thanks for trying I
appreciate
it also this is kind of dramatic
music oh go down in the hole that's
probably not a bad idea for your
health wait you guys fight oh
what the slice
stupid all right we should be
close no where are you I'm back this is
like way back there isn't
it is this way back this is
like I don't know I think that back if
you're not in that other room in like
okay this is the long range one yeah
right we're going to have to push a good
here Rob p p push it real good try I
believe in
you
damn nicely duck sorry that was loud
sorry about the headphones you can
it here we go oh wish I had that
rod
surprised how like the guys who I just
ran past gave
up so that's the Perils of running past
dudes you of sometimes you don't get the
clean checkpoint right this time did you
it's like kind of did
this you got cled so bad look at all
your purple blood you're so weird with
your purple blood I don't know why you
have I don't know why why they gave you
purple blood it's not your blood I know
it's
not blood is
red whoa not do that again whoa throwing
stuff around
physics it's like they're doing it on
purpose Christ happened
again
uhoh this is not looking too hot
I'm really trying okay
it just do it to
it find out where it is and do it to
it we'll just run by these guys oh
what all right I'm going try to do
it yeah Serpentine
motions see guys do not follow me it
guys I'm I'm way I'm way far gone now
you might
consider that door God I got nothing for
one
shoter oh did he follow me in he
did what a
joy what's down in the
middle like jump down in that middle
hole or just peek down in there
okay definely want to go down there I
think it's like an
elevator you think you have to kill all
these guys well you've got one shot
Rob
whoa all right where's your checkpoint
oh man I really want to see the next all
right well can we just like skip we can
just skip and play the beginning of the
next level right no cuz that's the
beginning cut scene for the next level
not the end cut scene for this
level it is not allowed why don't you
play this one in old timey
Graphics
yeah
wow why you even messing with those guys
I don't know I'm being an idiot I know
you want to kill things and I admire
that about you okay here we go video
game landia but this is live
streams oh he's got a r gun get it yeah
do I have a
COR wao
God you twisted your you tore your ACL
that time that's why you fell down okay
let's try this
again don't stand behind the things they
love to shoot him all right yeah they
were just go Serpentine Serpentine
motions Rob all right let's do
that Lama crap friend see you later see
you
dude not come
in keep running you might consider this
out portana can't just you know it's not
helpful sh
it's going to get
real oh
yeah no no you put that down put that
down immediately not this
time dude he did like like a back swing
that last time that's right brutal that
was not
great are there like four hunters in
here
now can you imagine
this oh God oh
God yeah
Rodeo nice little Matador action there
God i' stepping
it you want to check the door behind you
like oh this is good look at it no this
is looking good no I think you're
feeling we're feeling strong here don't
get cocky all right don't get copy yeah
fight each
other Joes yeah huge
Joes this guitar
wailing oh yeah oh hey hey
guys
yeah quick on that carbine
finger who's
next got
it this is that bow
though
checkpoint walk right in there
they'll she's up there where am I
going City oh there we go oh come on
come
on oh no did that sck me nope you're
clean [__]
you [__]
you
oh some transponder thing happened so
yeah you have to like you're
searching this isn't good I getting
confirmed reports of flood leaving in
Amber cl's wreckage let's get the index
dude don't you is this really long isn't
like the flood arrives is that the same
oh please get it
sick split them up one of these
Fantom yeah do the little switch so you
can switch the cut
scenes the hopes of all the Covenant
rest on your shoulders Chieftain I don't
really want to switch my faith is strong
I will not
fail let him
be the great journey Waits for No One
brother not even
you
regret oh look at
this oh nasty oh all
right sweet so that was gravem the level
from Halo 2 Anniversary that was hello
long uh we've got we can show you guys
Halo 3 and Halo 4 as well we'll just do
that pretty briefly and then wrap it up
um obviously we want to spend a lot of
time on Halo 2 Anniversary because
that's sort of the new uh the one that's
gotten the anniversary treatment it
looks super
good
um but yeah yeah we can only play one
level per Halo in the Master Chief
Collection so uh start get me out of
here no oh stop it uhoh all right we
can't show this so please uh switch away
from that thing I might have to quit the
game you can do it there okay oh God do
it in game you can do it now all right
here we go we're fine Xbox un I managed
to snap hold
on wow that was that was some Panic
tapping I won't lie here we go save and
quit save and quit because you do want
to play that later oh I'll come back to
it oh
baby man I um not going to lie I was a
little scared that last that last run
getting a little overwhelming you did it
though Rob did it and that was on normal
difficulty so yeah heroic definitely
harder than I remembered it from
um when I played it before missions
mission is this SI 117 Sierra
117 Rally Point Alpha just y start at
the beginning right the beginning we're
going to see time HUD we'll leave that
off yeah for those of you who haven't
seen this selection yet it's sort of a
multi-stage process when you're
selecting a mission to play within a
given Halo game first you select a
mission they are all unlocked from the
get-go from all the four Halo games uh
then you get to choose your options
about your scoring and time HUD if you
want to do a score run or not uh then
you choose the difficulty level we're
just going to choose normal so we can
Breeze through it uh for you guys and
then skulls of course you've got the a
whole variety of these uh some of them
are non-scoring like acceleration
explosions grunt head shots yeah we'll
put on grunt birthday rare combat
dialogue becomes more common sure let's
put that on there um and then of course
those don't multiply your score at all
so they're just kind of funsies you
going to do the head shot one the candle
one is that when their heads explode
like confetti yes okay grunt birthday
party uh and then yeah you just fire it
right up and so this is Halo 3 it's uh I
feel like it's like maybe been kicked up
to run at 60 frames per second or
something like that but it has not
gotten the anniversary treatment
basically the anniversary treatment is
like this game wasn't an HD now we're
going to make it an HD uh Halo 3 was in
HD granted it was like
2007 HD right but HD nonetheless
HD uh it's okay I'm a ninja in the
twitch chat wondering is it just me the
actual game video very
dark has been a little dark but then
also in time it's sort of uh a little
bit it
depends you're at so this is after uh
wait this three do you think that by
starting at Rally Point we missed the
intro cut scene or is it just the first
cut scene cuz remember you like let's
get moving Chief come on I'll lead you
out you like Rond de with the Arbiter
and he's in like you you fall from space
you hit the ground this is the thing
that you were in well I'm pretty sure
this cut scene opens up with like
Johnson like yeah showing up and then
you like shove the pistol at ARB face I
you could try restarting okay we're just
going to look at some Halo 3 real quick
forget it and so yeah there's no switch
to be done right that button is
useless and we're just going to go
through the jungle here and see what you
guys think of La jungla in Halo 3 looks
goodl
we'll only play this for a wee bit
yeah but what do you think of Halo 2 Rob
that was great
uh just it's just stalgia man feeling
feeling those levels the B dance feeling
the flow feeling the flow the switch is
insane I mean that's constant that
switch effect yeah that's just that's
like addicting I'm curious to know what
you guys think in the chat like
obviously watching us do the switch can
get a little
disorienting uh but like do you think
you would do the switch look at these
guys doing what Master Chief can
do look at us Chief guys I can I
can you Rich
Chief
but like are you guys thinking you'll
want to do the switch
or are you thinking that you'll just
keep it on the new anniversary situation
I'm
curious yeah I
mean this
guy can you see me over here buddy tap
tap
misses no yeah run birthday party come
here oh that's right equipment in Halo 3
remember that the bubble Shield do you
remember that trailer was just about to
say that trailer was the bees knees the
bees knees as they say oh my God he
drops
that that was so sick that trailer was
awesome all right tra to get some
birthday head shot here I was about to
say
um doing the switch in Halo 2 kind of
breaks immersion like I I think I might
not do it as often maybe certain moments
like just cu eyes kind of adjust to a
certain way the world is
yeah as I was about to say breaking
immersion this grunt's head exploded and
children started
screaming like that
hooray that I'm sorry I could not that
is not a skull like a you
on oh yeah give me I can't stupid brute
gun what are he called
Spiker nice work Arbiter they love you
Arbiter hooray they love you they really
do forgot about this thing
mhm so
stupid so not
annoying oh my God yes I understand that
my energy Shields are
down wonder if I can turn those off nice
setting no you I think you go down can
you go down down where yeah what you
want me to turn off birthday party I
thought you trying to turn off birthday
party
no front birthday party uh no I think
it's automatically on for
normal for the
children shooting up a dead
body isar
when we are victorious all who serve the
prophets will be
punished thanks AR it's funny how they
like brought back like a pistol and Halo
and assault rifle people were like I
remember like people being frustrated
like oh they took out the pistol and
they threw in the Magnum or whatever
that other one was they were like God
damn it pistol rocks at the name of the
actual pistol the name of
it
sleepers take them out nice and quiet oh
man I was just about to have a birthday
party
Fu
fine sleepers is what he calls them
delightful
oh look at he's like spinning
out Miss blood go to bed sweet prince
I want to do wield my spikers I don't
care about killing these sleepers while
they're
sleepies why he doesn't use it he
dropped it
it eat it oh
yeah guys going to a
party spikers dual spikers man did you
ever use
these like
is not
really is there like separate reload
button okay go under the
thing oh boy getting mildly bombarded I
see some equipment
drops can you hear the grunt say I'm not
going after
him
oh let's righty you turned on um more
dialog oh nice
shot that armor off
too oh my birthday party for
you so yeah this is Halo
3 uh we're going to maybe be out of this
jungle in a sec and then we'll just take
a look at Halo 4 real quick so you guys
can get a taste of it all uh let me know
oh no
die oh drop him you put him down you
damn he
just [__] that dude up yeah that's SM
bad we will have a birthday party in his
honor you would love this
party just one thing he liked it was
confetti spewing out from the brains of
his foes never
mind don't worry guys I'll SC out no
worries he just said guy just said don't
worry glad they understand
your
you
oo I love it up close and
personal what was it called like more
more random dialogue skull like rare
dialogue rare
is like
increased so yeah they went back they're
talking all the time like this is back
to the
uh the more crystall likee Needler
look oh oh that's right could you
sacrifice me to complete your
mission could you watch me
die Shakespeare sir you okay your vital
just
KIA
KIA no I just Cortana is freaking out
it's cool it's cool guys Charlie Fox
Trot oh yeah I'm confiscating this oh
yeah me
that oh went
down
ho okay great it's good
suggestion oh oh
banshees come and light them
up oh
no they are going
down oh no oh yeah there's this like oh
oh damn almost had it
every
time find y yon janson's crash
Pelican
nice classic just like calmly walking
forward that's sort of what Halo feels
like when you're used to like playing
games where there's like a Sprint it's
just you just calmly are walking the
same speed everywhere
where oh yeah
clap that's right it's only I didn't
realize it's only grunts to the uh
birthday oh yeah it's a grunt birthday
is that a double birthday all born on
the same
day
God oh hurry back oh you got one oh I
have one what is the button for it is
the
question
hold it's lb
lb Le bumper
leum oh yeah this
one my
down
ohy you guys you guys got
that chilling over here Arbiter
chilling come on you
dumb get him on
a look at this dude's eyes freaking out
oh yeah silently kill that silently kill
him want to jump make
that not
happening nice oh
yeah coming to the pain
Dome what's up you want to snip me uh
come on take a
shot
hoay
taparoo all right what are you calling
for a vote skip to Halo 4 or finish Halo
3 skip
or let the voting commence skip to Halo
4 or keep going Halo 3
baby haven't seen Halo 3 in a long time
and the part is still
going pick up the bubble Shield off that
gruntilda see here Skip Skip Skip Skip
finish skip Forge sorry I can't do it
Skip Skip Skip Skip Skip Skip Skip Skip
Skip multier Skip Skip Skip sounds like
a lot of Skips go skip
skip what do we think it's it's an it's
the skips have it it's a land
slide all right let's go check out some
Halo 4 last game in the Master Chief
Collection which we're checking out
here and uh we'll see how good it looks
on the xbone from when you played it on
the
X360 that's right so for for the record
Halo 3 the only major difference
is uh was 60 frames instead of 30 then
Halo 4 I guess is probably the
same which one do we get to play for
this one Infinity that's
right can we just watch the prologue
though prologue is so good it's so good
good Catherine Hy she's so
badass all right we're going to go back
to the
Jungle the most important do not
underestimate underestimate him what is
the quick quick start is just
start you at the beginning of the
campaign so yeah
then Infinity oh that's when you uh mhm
oh it's it's kind of like the same
almost the same level I feel like just
in a forest you want to play this one
sure do it Doug it is own I love Halo 4
I enjoyed
it uh so just to clarify again this will
be the last level we play on the live
stream today the reason that we're
allowed to stream the Master Chief
Collection here is because uh Folks at
Microsoft and 343 Industries got us the
review code early they said go ahead and
stream one level from each of the Halo
games in there very specific level uh so
we did the silent cartographer from
Combat Evolved we did grave mind from
Halo 2 Anniversary we did uh just a
glimpse of Sierra 117 from Halo 3 and
now we're here in Infinity in Halo 4
Chief we are not not allowed to show any
multiplayer or any Forge or really
anything else except those four levels
the ship looks intact but the game's com
out in two weeks and the review embargo
is up next Friday so
DN there this is Sierra 117 of the UNC
forward under Dawn we're on station
ready to
assist
multiplayer signals bouncing in and out
can't clean it
up light up their friender faux tags
we're going to need something to zero in
on ah yes the giant alien pinball from
Beyond the
moon ding d d ding ding
ding yeah you like that inverted look
invert you invert it's
good it's real good I'm
see the
on whoa
so yeah a bit of a difference in Jungle
lushness from Halo 3 to Halo 4 of course
there's like six years between those two
releases or something like that haveed
his distress
call that's right and
Sprint look at that oh look at that
you're running like a real
boy
oh oh yeah
Prometheans get freaky one of them's an
officer Che his tag I remember the first
time they did that warp thing where they
dashed right through your face yep first
time I did that definitely reacted oh
God love the
DMR else we got here did you review the
tags over there oh that's what I
supposed to to thank you Chris apprciate
that you know what they call me
Mr way point
about
terrible know how that sorry I didn't
hear anything where the hell do I
go oh I'm blowing it right now Jesus
Christ yeah these Halo 3 and Halo 4 are
six years and like four Halo games apart
depending on how you account cuz it was
Halo 3 then Halo Wars the RTS came out
and then Halo 3 ODST then Halo Reach
then Combat Evolved Anniversary and then
Halo 4 of course Combat Evolved
Anniversary and Halo 4 being the first
ones that 343 Industries took the lead
on all right help me out again where the
hell oh God it's this way isn't it
Jesus oh yeah the little doggies shoot
him in the face hey
guys oh they get so angry
God that sound on the
TMR it's so good love this
gun so we can't uh play multiplayer as
I've mentioned many times before much to
the Chagrin of all but we can talk a
little bit about multiplayer uh reading
up about sort of how they're handling
the ranking systems and there are going
to be separate XP systems for each Halo
game so when Halo 2 came out and made
Xbox Live Like the place to be uh you
you would gain rank in that but you
could also lose rank which is not
something you've been able to do in Halo
multiplayers since but they'll bringing
it back so you will be able to like you
do poorly in a match you're going to get
penalized and you're going to lose Rank
and I don't know I'm excited to have
that back cuz I haven't sort of uh
played a shooter with that kind of level
play in a while with that like yeah
right that little extra like losing
matters kind of thing you know losing
isn't just advancing slower it's
actually retreating and so what was the
problem with that well quitting
obviously was a problem with that uh and
you know I'm not sure exactly how 343 is
going to handle people quitting if
that's going to be an experience loss
because it's hard to tell right is it
just oh I lost my internet connection I
shouldn't be penalized for that or if
it's really crap this game's going
poorly let me let me get out uh but I
think on the whole I'm excited for it to
come back and to like have that little
extra urgency of and that then that
makes the rank mean a little something
more I
mean I don't know it'll be interesting
to see if the culture around the
multiplayer changes cuz it was kind
of some sometimes you play and it was
really fun and other times you play and
dudes would get super pissy about their
rank going down it's like all right I
understand rank matters and it's
something you want like you care about
but like get a little perspective here
guys honestly it's a tiny number on a
screen even like letting your friend
play a match yeah like like
no you can be a
guest the B
shot I love how that thing freaks out
when it charges up it does like
man it's weird I keep crouching cuz I'm
trying to punch oh really yeah oh yeah
cuz you you haven't like Reiger it for
your preference uh of controls oh yeah
the Halo too
was this is what they've been using
to
uhoh miss
that blam hey guys what's up friends
what's up alien Robo
pooches plow could plow I love the
scatter
shot oh
the shotgun is so sick the Promethean
shotgun it kind of like bounces the
Ricochet it's so much
fun how am I
doing Asher madon wonders why is there
even a review we already know the scores
to all the games uh yeah for the review
we're just going to add up all the
scores from all the games and divide by
four to get an average then for the text
we're just going to take all of the
paragraphs from all the four reviews and
do like a random selection of them and
just put a new intro and a new closer on
it call it a
day that's a wrap uh we're going to
write a review for it because it's like
it's a separate game and uh you know on
a certain level it's a it's a product
and some people like use reviews uh to
help them make purchasing decisions and
so we want to have something available
for that and also just kind of analyze
what it's like to uh have the like a
collection like this I think it's really
fascinating because really the the
anniversary editions of Halo Combat
evolv and Halo 2 are something distinct
from other games that have done HD
remakes or re-releases
because not only have they sort of done
the updated art style uh art and sound
and all that stuff recorded but they've
also uh added in new lore and stuff and
kind of modernized it so that it is that
thing alive or dead USIC kind of
modernized it uh to to keep
it accessible I guess you know to keep
it playable uh even even just playable
on a current system you know to play
Combat Evolved you would have to find an
old Xbox and hopefully it still works
and hopefully you have the disc that's
not scratched and stuff like that uh or
you play Combat Evolved Anniversary
which is available digitally I think on
a 360 or at the very least on a 360 uh
disc and part of the Master Chief
Collection as well
I think that within video gaming uh
especially console gaming not so much PC
gaming although PC gaming a little bit
too what are you doing I don't know like
history And archiving games and making
them playable a decade two decades after
they came out oh you brought it back to
life only me to shoot it that was very
there's my guy very thoughtful of you uh
is a real issue right you know like uh
the a lot of early games are in current
St where they're lost to history they're
not playable you can't find it and even
if you do you have to like uh delve up
some kind of old Tech and be willing to
invest the money in time to repair it
and get it working uh you know I think
that one way to do it is the Master
Chief Collection is to have a company
sort of invests the resources in
revamping the game and packaging it with
new versions with the newer iterations
of the game uh
and of course of course that's only you
know probably only going to be
commercially viable for games like Halo
for like big franchises but still like I
think it's really interesting and has a
lot of
value and it's kind of interesting to
see how 343 goes about it like what you
know what should the structure of a
thing of a of a game like this be how do
you preserve the things that made that
game magical back in the day but also
updated how do you preserve the
multiplayer how is that even going to
work with like 100 plus Maps that's
going to be boners how are they going to
all that stuff I don't know and uh you
know of course we're both chomping at
the bit to play multiplayer as are like
tons of you uh you know can't wait I
think it's going to be it's there's some
interesting stuff to talk about and so
that is a long-winded reason why there's
going to be a review I hope you read
itats are you going to play all
four I probably won't play all four to
complete
yeah uh I definitely will play all four
and the multiplayer for all four and
sort of and stuff like that oh going to
me a is this Sarah Palmer yeah I think
you're
right I mean I guess we met her in Chief
they're friendlies yeah a previous one
oh yeah let's just check
out Sarah Palmer you're bad he is a bad
we're going to give you
Tom first off that's my I'd see you SE
her
up you ever play any of
the yes and uh that stuff will be coming
out as downloadable content for the
master okay cool I think in December
they're bringing it out M um but yeah
that was Sarah Palmer's G that was
pretty neat it was kind of
uh it was a really cool experiment in
sort of downloadable content and how to
keep a game story going outside of a
main
release Side Story different different
story with like the infinity and what
that went
through that one I don't know if you
remember like the cut scene of spops
where it's like she's talking or
something like that and infinity goes
through remember that cut scene and it
goes
bones a covant cruiser God and you're
like
oh that ship is Big give a plows through
it so tight I don't know if it's too
soon to ask you for a favor but he bones
it we're going to run out of breathing
room here real
quick I don't suppose you're any good at
clearing LZ lasy on
occas I'll send out an all clear once
suppose you're any good at clearing
lzs all right I think it's a good stop
uh that
is first that's a good look at the
Master Chief Collection uh we played
Combat Evolved
Anniversary Halo 2 Anniversary Halo 3
Halo 4 all in there of course we were
only allowed to show one level from each
campaign and thus we did uh we're going
to be trying to show you guys some
multiplayer just as soon as we can CU
we're super eager to get into it as well
absolutely
uh that's a wrap folks to rap I'm Chris
Rob Rob thanks for watching go Giants